c'est la france que j'aime la france
perde les gens pauvres c'est une famille
extraordinaire une famille qui n'a pas
de ressources les deux parents sont rsa
c'est des gens méritants et là bon la
somme est exceptionnel mais c'est parce
qu'il ya l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire qui est pas là tous les mois
mais je trouve ça formidable ça c'est la
france que j'aime on aide les gens
voyaient bravo
alors gilles c'est vrai qu'hier ça a été
un déferlement sur le réseau et ses
rythmes à moi je vous ai dit ce que j'en
pensais qu'elle est ce que vous vous ou
voilà vous persistez je maintiens bien
sûr bien sûr c'est la france que j'aime
c'est pas la france de la feignantise
c'est la frange de l'as de la solidarité
c'est la défense
pardon le tas france de quoi vous je
sais pas mais moi je suis la france de
ceux qui doivent être aidés eux ils ont
besoin des forces de jours ils ont
besoin d'être aidés et je trouve que le
débat d'hier était trop dur pour eux et
quand on dit franchement quand on est
pauvre il faut pas avoir dix enfants etc
ça c'est méchant parce que c'est comme
quand on instaure un contrôle des
naissances en chine quand on empêche les
gens pauvres d'avoir des enfants le
débat est parti loin moi je maintiens
tout mes propos et je fais très fier
même si les gens contestent d'avoir dit
que ces gens méritaient leur allocation
alors j'ai jean-michel d'été palais hier
telle ou telle niche d'origine mais j'ai
regardé le débat et jared devait balle
j'étais évidemment pas du tout pour
origine voilà sur des affligés par les
propos de gilles une fois encore est
plutôt d'accord avec géraldine beats la
couche j'ai eu comme un éclair comme ça
je me dis qu'en fait gilles il voulait
tellement faire plaisir à fatou c'était
devenu en fait je remarque donc une
faute oui c'est le gère pas la clope
qu'elle lui a mis un bras ton cul
elle le fait parler comme ça et en fait
il ne le mérite pas du tout quel rapport
il fatto tom kendra parce qu'il n'était
pas du tout sûr que fat wreck moineau la
location n'est pas d'accord ah non non
pas que je la connais les fadas comme ça
tous attendu sa touche parce que
despatie a pas tout dit reconnaît il mon
amoureux c'est la voix fatiguée il est
une musique parfois des raids avec un
bras dans le cul comme ça
c'est fatal à travers lui et meurtri lot
de photos abbaoui
bien fort
du droit aed moi qui connais pas tout je
peux vous le dire elle et elle n'est pas
du tout d'accord avec lui semble un
tsunami fatou et elle elle se rapproche
beaucoup de moi on est on a beaucoup de
points communs d'ailleurs arrêtez-vous
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
et
il est déjà connu arrêté au un bon vous
allez pas je pense que
[Rires]
c'est
parce que la proche pas vous y allez oui
comme vous y allez mais moi aussi
j'étais pas là hier oui alors bonsoir
vous en pensez quoi je suis évidemment
contre gilles je compte contre gym selon
moi je pense à tous ceux qui ne demande
jamais rien qui crèvent tous seuls dans
leur coin comme les équipes exactement
c'est ce que disait hier il n'avait pas
donné l'exemple des agriculteurs je
pense à eux aussi les mecs qui se lève à
6h comme un cas qui se couche à 10 qui
c'est qui vise à 19h et qu'ils n'ont pas
et qui travaillent comme des fous et
qu'ils ont pas pour pour aller manger
faire manger leurs enfants et qu'ils
disent action le 15 du mois comment on
va faire je dirais que isabelle je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi là dessus
et on est tous d'accord mais lui dit
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre mais il dit
n'importe quoi mais il en est il en
train de bouger l'homme et la cdc self à
tous qu'ils ont fait bouger willy chan
alors d'abord jeu on peut quand même
remercier gilles parce que grâce à lui
il ya du débat en effet il n'a pas osé y
avait là ce courage de ses convictions
même si ce n'était pas normal n ouais
pour moi c'est un monde parallèle blanc
de démagogie mais malgré tout il le
pense et moi je me battrai toujours pour
qu'ils puissent exprimer ses avis même
débat quasi tous les miens bon ça c'est
la première chose ensuite comment tu te
sens j parce que ton candidat monsieur
fabien roussel t'avais dit que tu avais
voté pour lui lui dit justement qu'il
exècre honnête france déclare fait de la
politique m'intéresse pas parmi les
candidates
pour lui et finalement t'es pas d'accord
avec lui et on en vient ça prouve que
problème tu es un petit peu à géométrie
variable et moi j'en celui annoncé
brutalement parce que lui veut que la
france travaille il veut aider ceux qui
travaillent il veut aider les premiers
corps d aider les gilet jaune il veut
aider ceux qui sont en vraie fragilité
et il veut pas une fronde assister et ça
marche pense que c'est ça la vraie
france social en fait mais vous le
reprocher c'est dingue parce que vous en
arrivez alors reproché d'avoir dix
enfants et ne pas bosser mais c'est vrai
mais c'est jean-louis ces gens souffrent
c'est ça que vous ne comprenez pas vous
pensez que les gens pensent qu'ils
dépendent des allocations familiales
ils sont pas en bas c'est parce que des
mots ça n'arrive nommément de 56
jeunesse où dominent et elton john oui
soutient gilles je suis aussi rigide à
100% parce que c'est quelqu'un de
profondément humain qui se met toujours
à la place des gens moi cette politique
elle m'exaspère parce qu'elle tape sur
les pauvres gratuitement non rien aux
trucs qui m'énervent gratter les gens
qui critiquent ne disent pas le fond de
leur pensée le fond de leur pensée c'est
quoi c'est qu'un petit détail sur
l'affiché que les gens qui ont publiées
sans soigneusement oublié d'effacer le
nom saïd en eau qui a quand même une
conne
[Applaudissements]
dès qu'on sait c'est que vous dites ah
bah voilà les
du système alors que les bourses et de
sous genres et
même à aller voir sur les réseaux
intelligents dit vous avez vous aggravez
des amalgames racistes et dégueulasse
nations mais les doutes alors s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît vraiment que tu
portes des conneries guillaume elles
sont beaucoup mais tu es d'habitude tu
es tout le temps dans le bon là tu dis
des conneries il ya des français aussi
qui touchent des allocations familiales
yates il faut pas notre bon je ne veux
rien dire tu oublies sont censés inciter
d'accord mais parce que là où il parle
d'une
aura pas non plus et sous-entendu c'est
des immigrés n'ont pas effectué dix de
der une connerie moi je pense que gilles
et dans ses propos dans sa conviction il
a raison il ya des gens qui le pense
vraiment il ya des gens qui pensent
qu'il faut aider tout le monde en
échange de rien moi j'ai dit hier je
n'aiderai pas les gens en échange de
rien la joie 1700 euros je parle pas de
pauvreté mois à ce niveau là c'est pas
de la pauvreté et 6000 même qu'ils ont
touché là pour la rentrée scolaire je
peux pas parler de pauvreté en cinq mois
de temps ils vont gagner une année d'un
mec est partie travail était parti se
lever tous les matins en sort il ya
beaucoup d'eau sera pas bien beaucoup de
gens sur les réseaux qui disent qu ils
scrutent et à côté de la primature
guillaume tu as dit faut pas regarder
5008 ya 2000 qui est une allocation
annuelle donc c'est 3000 sayra
s'inquiète sacré bien 3000 à 4000
guillaume c'est l'équivalent bravo
catherine est c'est l'équivalent de six
mille brut mais il faut que ça veut dire
j'espère attendant temps d arrêter avec
ça pas un café ou planet
dire que ce monsieur en tout cas à moins
de 3 à moins 5000 euros brut pour un
boulot ce n'est pas la peine qu'ils
travaillent au mien qui est donc ce
monsieur c'est parce qu'il est habitué à
l'appel qui travaillent mais ces unions
c'est ignoble à droite
écoute moi je ne sais pas des escrocs
c'est joli ça vous mettriez trouve un
boulot à 6000 euros bruts mais il a
raison
il faut que c'est ça qu'ils disent et
est où le rugby au moins 1 fois pour qu
est ce que tu vas gagner ce que tu as
des commentaires monsieur on ne sait pas
ce qu'il avait l'habitude un boulot de
fait les brutes c'est à dire que ce
monsieur en gros pardon et je me mettre
à sa place n'a aucun intérêt plus jamais
il faudra un salaire à 7000 brut jean tu
comprends mais on y travaille dans le
vif tout il n'ira jamais à travailler
voilà tu pars du principe que les
pauvres ont un mauvais fond qui sont là
pour l'aider
non jamais l'oreille mais sinon c'est ma
faute si je
dis oui
on est le premier je te donne six mille
euros sans rien faire ou le 1er du mois
je te donne six mille euros net fond tu
travaille tous les jours 8 heures tu
prends quoi tu conçois pas que des gens
qui traversent des périodes difficiles
dans la vie je n'ai pas de travail ils
ne peuvent pas travailler
contre et la protection sociale ça sert
à aider les gens à retrouver à la rue
guillaume guillaume parfois il est
vraiment crise est tout le temps sur le
racisme elle est vraiment nul
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît prévu
que le plus grand des enfants
le plus grand des enfants avec les dom
mais on n'en veut pas à cette famille en
plus mais ils ont raison donc il ne
travaille pas ils ont raison des enfants
je ne sais pas quelle est quel âge elle
celui qui en dessous il a 19 ans mais il
pourrait travailler aussi prêté ses
risques alors arrêté son choix
sempre amis où l'enfant il travaille
parce que ses parents n'ont pas beaucoup
d'argent à lady lui qu'on a notre aval
et j'emmerde remet le nez c'est à deux
bras deux jambes des jeunes qui a rungis
tu portes des structures
attendez à tâtonner ce que je veux vous
redire c'est ce que j'aime bien la pays
ils sont rien contre la famille
le cadet le système qui équipe qu'il
guide et voilà qu'il est qui les énerve
c'est pas la famille la famille à la
limite c'est au contraire ils ont raison
eux ils font ils font ce qu'ils ont à
faire
lui s'en fout qui c'est qui finança
c'est un puits sans fond faut arrêter de
penser que ça c'est financé par le père
noël s'est financée par les gens qui
bossent allez dire à une heineken a une
maman qui s'est séparé du moment où les
logos les moments quelqu'un de trois
gosses à nourrir qu'elle est tout seul
et se bagarre tous les jours avec ses
1300 balle qui doit nourrir 7 dogan allé
lui dire qu'il ya des mecs qui restent
chez eux s'ils prennent 3007 bas je veux
rester chez moi et prend complètement
faux pas parler de provo pauvreté ou
algériens avec cette famille ils font ce
qu'ils veulent c'est juste le système
qu'il faut changer à mon argent c'est
les gens qui bossent qu'il donne sur une
adroite pas donné à tout le monde si
trop trop d'enfants comme des photos et
mes enfants je suis déjà non mais ça
coûte quitte à donner à part le
barracuda
jeté à terre comme des retours de pierre
michon les dix ans oui mais tais toi non
mais cela de nous a dit non mais elle
est en train de dire que le nombre
d'enfants est autorisée en fonction des
revenus c'est parfaitement ignobles elle
a dit ça alors
ça alors je peux te
mets moi j'ai c'est ce que je disais
hier ya plein de potes à moi à oui qui
me disent moi je vais pas faire un 3ème
enfant j'aurais pas les moyens de m'en
occuper j'ai pas les moyens j'obtiens
c'est un choix de vie ça veut dire quoi
comme étant barrée avec un certain
revenu on n'a pas droit de fermer le ban
mais pas dit
s'ils veulent faire dix ans fait le
bonheur de faire des enfants
mais voilà elle retourne à la chine dans
les dictatures vous
permet de chine tapas une dalle par mois
que ça dure et
gilles verdez et écouter on peut
géraldine parle de messine différents
chine où on s'était enfin le lit
géraldine
mamet à un moment donné elle travaillait
elle est temps que gilles verdez je sais
pas dans quel monde y vibre déjà celui
qui tue mais pas dans le monde ait eu je
te disais et je te le redis c'est des
mecs comme toi qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
la france est en échec je te le redis je
le pense vraiment je le pense vraiment
banal ça n'importe quel mobile disco
finition
bien
d'abord film
c'est bon pour mac os ou pas non non
mais j'ai effectivement le montant
effectivement il est choquant mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors prenons
allons à l'extrême les gens qui ont
vraiment rien il voit là un couple ils
ont quatre enfants cinq enfants ils
n'ont pas de boulot qu'est ce qu'on fait
de ceux de ces gens là on les aide pas
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ce que je vous
dis vous dites voilà c'est une honte les
allocs ha légèrement anisé vous n'avez
vous pas des vignerons vous grande et
durable du doigt des personnes chez qui
ment profite d'un système qui existe qui
est là depuis des dangers pense qu'on
doit être suffisant
mais c'est parce que je veux pas être
blanc ou noir donc si tu dis c'est trop
on fait comment pour ceux qui ont
vraiment besoin d'argent
moi ce que je veux je voudrais dire ce
que je voudrais dire oui absolue c'est
que gilles gilles verdez excuse-moi
financer la france de l'échec oui oui
mais ça c'est moyen de ce que je vais le
redire et gilles tu ne comprends pas un
truc c'est que quand tu prends une
décision est un enfant c'est une
décision mais oui c'est une décision que
je vis et décision de condamnation quand
on a trois quatre cinq enfants c'est une
décision aussi économiques en vrai on va
pas se mentir il dit voilà comment ce
fait perdu devoir avoir peut-être
apprendre en tapas la voiture j'ai
devoir la changer je vais devoir avoir
battu devoir faire plus de recours et
non mais moi je parle avec avec moins de
téléspectateurs voilà sur les réseaux vu
que je vois ce qu'ils disent et il dit
ils réfléchissent à tous ils ont peur de
l'avenir ils disent comment on va faire
est ce qu'on va faire un enfant bien
dans un corps utilise comme on va se
débrouiller comment on va finir le mois
combien chômage et de messages par loin
de gens qui me disent on travaille tiré
dix heures par jour on n'arrive pas à
s'en sortir et voilà et toi qu'est ce
que tu raconte gilles quand tu dis on
fait le nombre d'enfants qu'on veut oui
mais ne dit pas de nos outils non mais
ne dit pas de bêtise c'est comme si tu
disais pour la norme est celle où si tu
le disais alors vas tu sais quoi et bat
tout le monde va vite dans un sens un
coup de maître car il voit là bas c'est
comme ça toute ma vie s'est il est parlé
dans les syndicats
alors pourquoi j'ai pas le droit de
mourir au
cdis épi part du principe que c'est
l'état qui va les éduquer à tallinn
c'est un mépris pour l'enfant est alors
pardonnez moi mais non on a fait la
semaine de l'emploi rtr des gens qui ne
des entrepreneurs quillan tous les
domaines
saisonniers
vraiment chéri des salariés est baladé
son départ
n'est pas du tout opposée aux
allocations longue loin de là on dit
qu'il faut simplement un moment plafonné
je suis effectivement il ya des choix de
vie et coop l'admettons à partir de cinq
enfants bat durera pas plus donc si tu
peux rentrer manche
gilles on sait quand tu le fais par les
fêtes ça le fait pas s'il n'y a pas de
contraception si on se trouvait une dix
enfants il y en a cinq qui manche il
a raison il ya des gens pour des
questions religieuses aussi
fusée moi et pas des exceptions je suis
désolé il n'y a pas d'exception la seule
nuance et si tu as déjà dans la nuit les
enfants ou les neuf enfants il t'arrive
un accident de vie peut-être que tu peux
avoir mais faut souvent fait défaut des
délais tu peux pas toucher 10 à 15 ans
delphine mais gilles a quand même si tu
ne peut pas subvenir aux besoins d'un
enfant tu n'en fais pas 10g d'accord non
seulement si tu ne peut pas subvenir à
un enfant tu n'en fais pas 10 mais
aujourd'hui en france c'est plus
difficile de subvenir à un enfant khady
sarr ios des allocations si tu veux
excuser la courbe elle est inversée
puisque c'est ma mère s'il te plaît ah
oui c'est vraiment ma mère oui bah je
sais pas vraiment elle avait mis des
boulettes dans du papier alu seaway 6
décès des filles
superbes arribas m
lèvres ce que je te dis dans le sens oui
et moi c'est l'humain et vous c'est les
mathématiques c'est ça que je reproche
elle a bien sûr aujourd'hui vers d'elle
aujourd'hui pour un non sens si on avait
un président comme toi mais ce ne serait
pas la faillite déjà qu'ils aient déjà
que cette douleur mais lui mais à toi
bien tu sais non mais c'est en hongrie
c'est vrai la france a besoin d'être
dirigé par un chef d'entreprise oui et
je pense vraiment je suis pas la bonne
personne
il a raison c'est que tu m'énerves et
régions où tu peux avoir un travail
avoir avoir un travail les deux boss et
tu fais un enfant 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 tu les
as déjà fait et arrive un accident de
vie la vie donne ce montant l'année à là
éternellement c'est là qu'il a raison on
peut pas dire tu as tu fait quatre
enfants il y en a ils ont fait huit
enfants il avait une situation mais nous
les nourrir ensuite ça bascule il ya des
accidents
j'ai mon ami je savais de gironde
rodriguez qui me dit un truc pas coup
moi j'ai mon avis je t'embrasse dire aux
gens les plus grands bassistes et de
france aussi les grandes entreprises
mais on appelle ça des subventions comme
par exemple un milliard voilà qu'ils
sont 10 milliards qui sont distribués çà
c'est vrai aussi il ya des aides
incroyable si voilà des sujets dits
d'accord c'est aussi je vous dis moi
j'ai des potes pas ils ont des aides à
s'en aller ou des années partout il a
dit qu'elle avait arrimé c'est un truc
si vous voulez dire qu'on est très très
riches sont favorisés et les très
pauvres mal mais on est d'accord avc le
milieu qui paye tout à l'heure
mieux
sur cette poche les armes du cac 40
paient en moyenne en impôts sur les
revenus de fans impôt sur les sociétés
cette mairie mec c'est ce que disaient
les gilet jaune et noir c'est que sans
la chine on jouera les gilet jaune qui
tenait à la russe et tous les gars qui
travaillent et qui disait at the 10 du
mois on est dans la merde comment ça se
fait qu'on travaille qu'on a qu'on soit
dans la merde comment ça se passe c'est
pas possible moi j'ai beaucoup plus
choqué par la caissière gagne 1200 euros
par mois qui travaillent la pâte bill
guerin bas mais non mais non mais
moi pour revaloriser tous ses bas
salaires les infirmiers les rings sur
les instituteurs ce n'est pas
incompatible on peut
évoquer en moi je viendrai moi je suis
beaucoup plus choqué par la caissière
qui les 1200 euros par mois
c'est bien ça
non mais voilà mes gilles on va voir ce
que pensent encore l'image ils insultent
tous les genres journée
parce que tous les gens d'aujourd'hui
qui vient des gens qui travaillent ici
aussi les gens travaillent pas mais toi
tu es toujours du mauvais côté tout tu
veux doit toujours du côté des
mais s'il ya un moment il faut
récompenser les gens qui travaillent et
saturn dépassant les gens qui ne
travaillent pas au clip c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça les résultats et mercerie
regard des séances merci merci aux voix
tiens
prenez vous le tollé oui oui gary whitta
fin pol et au lit tôt libre enfin ça
pour ça c'est bien nataf un tollé jamais
25% qui comprend l'esprit
[Applaudissements]